[Música]
vocês sabem qual é o 21º maior país do
mundo
esse país é do tamanho do reino unido é
um país em que albert einstein anne
frank em outro momento histórico teria
morado quando eu visitei alguns campos
de refugiados e campos de deslocados
eu estava procurando por um por um
direito chamado liberdade de movimento e
eu encontrei mais do que isso encontrei
um movimento inclusive composto por
refugiados por migrantes por deslocadas
à força de liberdade
essa é uma foto que eu tirei no campo de
memória no norte da grécia lésbicas em
uma ilha chamada legions e eu comecei a
me interessar alguns anos e cada dia
mais a contar essas histórias de vida e
fazer algumas perguntas do tipo quando
as pessoas foram forçadas a fugir de
casa
hoje no mundo onde elas estão e isso me
lembrou dois autores o irmão até lário
ficou uma tela tem uma frase muito
interessante que ele que ele diz o
seguinte no século 19
as pessoas começaram a desenvolver a
estatística istat que é muito importante
alguns de vocês sabem disso porque os
dados são importantes para políticas
públicas e começaram a contar as
estatísticas contar às pessoas e à
reflexão martelar é que em algum momento
a gente esqueceu de contar a história
das pessoas e começou a contar apenas os
dados
então essa é a minha proposta é o meu
convite pra vocês porque vocês conta m
lembrou também do focou porque há o
fluxo de refugiados me lembrou a
história que o fogo conta né num livro
muito interessante chamada história da
loucura em que ele conta como que houve
isolamento das cidades européias em
relação aos chamados na época leprosos
durante a idade média
depois disso foi substituído pelos pelas
pessoas com doenças venéreas não tinha
nada a ver com saúde
pública depois foi substituído pelos
loucos chamados loucos e hoje me
pergunto quem são os novos os nove
segmentos da sociedade que a gente tenta
isolar
então eu quando visitei diversos campos
de refugiados e e conversei com vários
refugiados pelo mundo e ouvir histórias
de isolamento em memória norte da grécia
em uma cidade francesa de macalé num
campo informal de refugiado chamado
lajão na selva e o isolamento não é só
geographic channel também é
comunicacional cheguei em legions por
exemplo e ocampo demora não tinha
internet
as pessoas estavam sendo impedidos de
falar com as suas próprias famílias e
tem informação de direitos e tudo mais
e ele também é cultural é da xenofobia
por exemplo
e quando eu converso com essas pessoas
pessoas super outra lucidez inteligentes
a gente conversa sobre tudo sobre a
situação política sobre o neymar quando
eles ficam sabendo que eu sou brasileiro
sobre os ricos
algumas pessoas mais antigas ea única
coisa que eles me pedem isso é uma nota
que eu queria fazer
a única coisa em todos os lugares era
cigarro
eu fiquei eu não fumo infelizmente eu
teria comprado márcio e marços cigarro
poderia aproximar das pessoas mais e eu
fiquei muito curioso porque a única
coisa que despejou de cigarro e optando
assim dizer como é que essas pessoas
estão comendo então se alimentando e aí
a resposta foi sensacional porque eu
estava justamente indo pra fazer
voluntariado no ano passado na grécia
este ano na frança na turquia e eles
disseram são os voluntários que dão um
mínimo de subsistência para essas
pessoas que são as principais as mais
vulneráveis na sociedade
quantos são 65 milhões contar
quantificar também importantes são 65
milhões de pessoas deslocadas hoje
existem 15 conflitos no mundo em
andamento um terço são de refugiados
a síria é uma das principais crises no
brasil a gente não sabe direito o que
que é isso são 40 mil solicitantes de
refúgio refugiados num todo
até agora isso dá uma semana de síria
a gente tem 22 milhões o sudão do sul e
miracatu e qual foto que eu poderia
colocar se eu quisesse representar essas
pessoas 50 por cento são crianças
eu não posso colocar a foto de criança
aqui então eu escolhi essa foto essa
foto foi feita por uma amiga que eu fiz
no norte da grécia que é uma fêmea
grande três anos e ela que fez esse
desenho
eu me nego a chamar ela de uma ameaça
eu me nego a chamar ela de ilegal porque
ninguém é ilegal e quem recebe quem está
recebendo refugiados é aonde eu fui
porque eu fui na grécia e na frança não
84 por cento das pessoas estão em países
de renda média ou baixa quase um terço
nos países mais pobres do mundo
é lá que eles estão é lá que está a
solidariedade principalmente a crise se
tiver no líbano onde um a cada seis
pessoas do país são refugiados a gente
tem meio por cento no brasil e que eles
estão fazendo esses países nesse caso os
migrantes são 445 bilhões de dólares por
ano enviados de volta para casa
e aí você se perguntar então estão
roubando desenvolvimento dos países não
85% desse dinheiro dos imigrantes fica
no país
eles estão na frança fica na frança ele
está na inglaterra fica na inglaterra é
esse pequena porcentagem de 15% que é
três vezes toda ajuda humanitária três
vezes toda a ajuda humanitária é mais do
que o investimento das empresas nos
países pobres é o dinheiro do trabalho
que é de 200 milhões de migrantes
econômicos que estão no treino 800
milhões de pessoas isso está trazendo
desenvolvimento da saúde e educação e
talvez seja o fim das guerras e as
histórias com as quais não me deparei
são sazonais
as pessoas são o principal em quando eu
me lembro por exemplo do irã
o sudanês que disse que não sofreu
preconceito com a polícia francesa
porque ele não parecia árabe
ele é do sudão ele fala árabe portanto
em árabe
ele tem identidade árabe ele é muçulmano
tinha todos os motivos para polícias e
xenófoba mas ela não era porque porque
ele não tem o fenótipo o preconceito é
burro
o nigeriano que não podia um amigo meu
nigeriano e lésbicas que não podia comer
em um restaurante porque o dono do
restaurante não aceitava o dinheiro dele
ele tinha dinheiro para comer em um
restaurante em legions numa ilha nossa
gracie não podia comer porque por
preconceito
o brasileiro um amigo meu que disse que
encontrou solidariedade e ele era grande
morador de rua encontrado solidariedade
entre os moradores de rua eram os
principais pessoas que ajudavam e os
próprios moradores de rua né e o branco
ac e eu tentando entrar na grécia fiquei
uma hora e meia no aeroporto porque eu
vim de um avião espanhol tinha um monte
de espanhol e duas pessoas diferentes um
latino e um romeno e eu fiquei uma hora
e meia parado perguntando por que eu sou
suspeito a barra e tá né então se
algumas pessoas sugeriram então vamos
fechar as fronteiras de uma vez por
todas as vezes acontece nunca vamos
fechar as fronteiras devolver todo mundo
não seria um bom negócio não olha os
dados estrangeiros no brasil nós temos
um milhão e meio por cento enquanto os
brasileiros nós temos no exterior dois
milhões e meio que geram 0,2 por cento
do pib brasileiro
por meio dessas remessas que eu estava
comentando
será que é uma questão de a gente tem
muito estrangeiro no país de novo eu
perguntar dados oficiais dos países
a frança tem 11% estrangeiros alemanha
em 12 estados unidos 14 o canadá 20 por
cento
a austrália tem 30% o brasil é
pequenininho dá pra ver
por cento será que é só isso será que
eles são o grande problema de um país
não sei você sabe que em inglês tem um
ele eles chamam pra estrangeiro também
nessa palavra n ã e antigamente a gente
usava invasão alienígena né invasão
alienígena era uma expressão eu gosto
muito de ler jornal velho dos dois
séculos anteriores parte da minha
pesquisa de doutorado e envasar eleja
uma expressão muito comum dos
nacionalistas na época
para nós que somos alguns aqui
descendentes de estrangeiros
nós somos a menos de três gerações
estrangeiros e descendentes pessoas que
chegaram a esse país para construir o
brasil e aqui de onde a gente veio esse
é o total de migrantes livres de 1884
2014 olha onde estão as bolas maiores
elas vieram da europa são italianos são
portugueses são espanhóis e da europa
que a gente veio entre outros lugares
claros migrantes livres têm açúcar a
história terrível de escravidão tem os a
emigração asiática tenha outras
os maiores vieram de lá a gente deve
muito eles deve muito ao brasil ea gente
deve muito aos estrangeiros
então eu fiquei me perguntando durante
essas andanças de qual crise que a gente
está falando
a minha impressão de que é uma crise de
solidariedade que existe essa é a maior
crise que existe essa frase sim desde
que você consuma foi dita por um dono de
um restaurante em calé uma cidade
minúscula que eu tive que andar duas
horas para encontrar os primeiros
refugiados minúscula menos 60 mil
pessoas não me lembro bem e eu tentei
usar o banheiro do restaurante porque
todos os banheiros da cidade estavam
quebrados e ele respondeu com isso sim
você pode usar desde que você consuma
essa foi a grande tragédia que eu
encontrei porque entre os refugiados
na verdade eu tinha muitas histórias de
esperança
eu tinha
jade que dividiam tudo de que dividir um
pouco que tinha que passavam o tempo
juntos apesar das culturas completamente
diferentes que compartilhavam as suas
dores
essa ong hellenic resque sim ganhou um
prêmio do da agência da onu para
refugiados aquino em 2016 porque eles
são uma ong que resgata qualquer tipo de
pessoa em perigo e eles salvaram 2500
pessoas foi lá que eu fui voluntária'
vocês devem estar se perguntando muitas
pessoas se pergunta como eu faço para
voluntariado
eu mandei um e mail perguntando como eu
faço para montar eu sei fazer isso isso
isso eu posso ir de graça vocês querem e
comprei em 12 vezes em minha passagem e
fui e conseguir me juntar esse grupo
maravilhoso que continua salvando muitas
vidas completou um ano que eles ganharam
esse prêmio nesta semana
e essas histórias são as histórias que
me deram fôlego eu cheguei nos locais de
voluntariado eu cheguei me junto aos
refugiados todos eles eram extremamente
esperançosos pessoas fortes que passaram
por muita dificuldade e tão tanto por
suas vidas e é muito triste que a gente
tenha uma onda de xenofobia que não
entenda que eles são seres humanos
porque todos os que eu conheci
então o meu convite
é justamente esse é o de vocês contarem
histórias de vocês se inspirarem a
partir desses exemplos de vida e
continuarem essa contratação coletiva e
um dia espero vá acabar de vez com a
xenofobia
obrigado
[Aplausos]